[Applaudissements]
Marseille Marseille 8 premières
nous sommes en 1978 Georges Marchais le
secrétaire général du Parti communiste
français est en campagne à Marseille
il est suivi par une équipe de cinéastes
alors je vais attendre 40 000 personnes
sont présentes mais il choisit de les
faire patienter
en homme d'images Georges Marchais sait
à quel point le cinéma est essentiel
pour ce que les communistes appellent
encore la propagande de parties
ce tournage est loin d'être le premier
des sacréation en 1920 le Parti
communiste français a développé une
intense activité cinématographique en
impulsant à la production la réalisation
et la diffusion de centaines de films La
Vie est à nous il a maintenant une
valeur plus historique que
cinématographique mais il y avait le
style de renoi
unique dans le champ politique français
le PCF peut être considéré comme le
parti du cinéma
[Musique]
c'est cette histoire que nous allons
vous raconter une épopée politique qui
exprime en creux le communisme à la
française fait d'espoir et de des routes
une saga cinématographique méconnue du
grand public qui n'a eu de cest
d'expérimenté et de se renouveler pour
contourner la censure
une aventure d'hommes et de femmes qui
ont fait le choix de militer par les
mages et de prendre le parti du cinéma
[Musique]
tu veux démolir les machines
ils en commandant
et puis sérieusement c'est pas les
machines regardez en Russie ils sont
arrivés à diminuer la journée de travail
à augmenter les salaires grâce aux
machines mais ici les gros ils
préfèrerait nous laisser crever de faim
plutôt que de baisser leur bénéfice
en 1936 le Parti communiste français
produit la vie est à nous
la réalisation ne se filme est confiée à
Jean Renoir pour la première fois un
parti politique produit un long métrage
dans des conditions professionnelles
avec l'ambition de le diffuser dans les
salles de cinéma
ça peut pas continuer
pour le PCF c'est l'aboutissement d'un
processus engagé 15 ans plus tôt
en décembre 1920 le congrès socialiste
réunis à Tours s'achève sur une scission
le Parti communiste voit le jour
suivant le modèle soviétique tous les
moyens de propagande possible doivent
être utilisés le cinéma apparaît
d’emblée très approprié pour faire de
l'agitation politique
accessible à tous jouant sur une
illusion de réel et potentiellement
reproductible à l'infini c'est pour
Lénine le plus important de tous les
arts
le PCF connaît ses premiers grands
succès électoraux en 1935
les nouvelles municipalités communistes
de la banlieue parisienne deviennent
immédiatement un terrain d'expérience
cinématographique des courts métrages
documentaires sont commandés pour
promouvoir l'action des maires
communistes
parmi ces films les châteaux du bonheur
et financés en 1936 par la ville de
Gennevilliers
[Musique]
devant vous va vous montrer
quelques-uns de nos efforts et en
particulier les résultats obtenus à
notre patronage municipal et dans nos
deux colonies de vacances cette mise en
scène du maire Jean Grandel bien qu'un
peu maladroite est une tentative de
communication directe par le cinéma qui
est vraiment novatrice pour l'époque le
jour du colonie de vacances
dernière recommandations surtout sois
bien ça tu nous écriras on promet tout
tant qu'on est content de partir quitte
à ne pas toujours tenir ses promesses
[Musique]
destinée à une diffusion locale et
château du bonheur apporte des preuves
par l'image de l'engagement de la
municipalité pour le bien-être des
enfants
journée son rythmées par de nombreuses
activités dont certaines sont
particulièrement fougueuses
[Musique]
l'enjeu est aussi éducatif que politique
il s'agit de montrer la capacité
d'encadrement et d'organisation des
communistes du berceau au tombeau
[Musique]
l'hygiène
la santé et surtout l'alimentation sont
attentivement surveillés
[Musique]
n'aura pas été vain peser à leur arrivée
à la colonie et à leur départ les
enfants ont accusé des augmentations de
poids dont les moyennes sont éloquents
au milieu des années 30 les communistes
les socialistes et les radicaux
s'unissent pour faire barrage ou
fascisme
le Front populaire est lancé
c'est pour soutenir la campagne du PCF
lors des législatives de juin 1936 que
le projet de la Vie est à nous est mis
en route
[Musique]
vient de Jacques Duclos responsable de
la propagande du parti et grand amateur
de cinéma par l'entremise de l'écrivain
communiste Louis Aragon le réalisateur
Jean Renoir et sollicité
il a alors une dizaine de films à son
actif il n'est pas connu pour ses idées
de gauche et hésite à participer
mais il partage sa vie avec la menteuse
Marguerite ou lait qui est proche des
milieux communistes
[Musique]
c'est sans doute elle qui est le pousse
à accepter
ait noir la vie te semble sans espoir
camarade reprend courage tu n'es pas
seul
tourner et monter en à peine un mois la
vie est à nous invente le film militant
en mélange fiction documentaire et même
actualités cinématographique détournée
plusieurs registres sont convoqués du
tragique au plus comique
[Musique]
la vie est à nous est en grande partie
construit autour de trois histoires
introduites par Marcel Cachin qui jouit
ici son propre rôle celui de directeur
du journal l'Humanité
Gennevilliers
tour à tour un ouvrier un jeune chômeur
et un paysan résolvent leurs problèmes
par l'intervention des communistes
Jean Renoir à accepter danser la
responsabilité d'un film ouvertement
propagandiste reste difficile à cerner
plus qu'un engagement politique c'est
peut-être pour lui l'opportunité de se
faire connaître d'un nouveau public au
moment où la France vibre pour le Front
populaire
mon père veut une théorie que j'aime
beaucoup c'est la théorie du bouchon il
disait faut être un bouchon un bouchon
dans le courant il faut suivre le
courant naturellement le bouchon doit
être un petit peu intelligent pas
complètement stupide et essayer
d'évoluer un peu à droite ou à gauche de
façon à choisir le moment du courant qui
lui convient le mieux et aller tout de
même à peu près dans une direction qui
lui convient mais la direction générale
c'est les événements c'est le courant
qui nous donne
[Musique]
dis donc
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces gens là ce
sont des camarades des ouvriers ils
viennent là le soir répéter il y a même
des professionnels qui les aiment tu
comprends nous ce qu'on voudrait c'est
ramener en France le goût de la musique
et du théâtre ce jeune homme à droite
qui fait une apparition c'est Jean-Paul
Le Chat Noir un des nombreux assistants
réalisateurs sur la vie est à nous s'il
doit beaucoup à Jean Renoir le film est
aussi et même avant tout une œuvre
collective c'est là où je peux dire que
Jacques Becker a fait ses premières
armes en tournant quelques plans
du sketch des paysans
[Musique]
et moi les miennes en tournant quelques
plans dans l'usine pour Jacques Becker
comme pour Jean-Paul Le Chanois c'est le
point de départ de belle carrière
cinématographiques tous deux seront des
réalisateurs reconnus dans les années 50
seul communiste de la bande Jean-Paul Le
Chanois devient la cheville ouvrière du
film en endossant le rôle de Directeur
de Production c'est lui qui gère les
finances
j'étais caissier mais ce n'était pas
lors de Moscou entre guillemets qui
payait le film ça a été un meeting
[Musique]
cette mise a contribution des militants
complètent l'argent donné par le PCF
c'est un mode de financement alternatif
rendu possible par l'engagement bénévole
des équipes techniques et artistiques
[Musique]
et heureuse que veulent et que feront
les communistes
vous les forces adoles après avoir donné
la parole aux dirigeants communistes
tous les personnages du film se
retrouvent pour chanter l'international
l'union du peuple est alors figuré et
célébrée pour incarner le programme du
Front populaire
[Musique]
par le film a été montré on le dit tous
évidemment un peu impatient de savoir
parce que le Parti communiste allait en
français et je me souviens que Renoir
était un peu dans ses petits souliers et
je me souviens surtout c'est que Maurice
Thorez a dit moi je trouve ça formidable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les élections ont lieu un mois plus tard
des voitures et des projecteurs 16 mm
sont achetés par le PCF pour que le film
puisse être montré n'importe où
[Musique]
en mai 1936 le Front populaire l'emporte
cette victoire politique renforce la
dynamique cinématographique
[Musique]
le temps des cerises il y a
vers la gare
lui est un film qui a été repris à la
suite du succès de la Vie est à nous
Jacques Duclos il a demandé il a dit il
faudrait que nous fassions un film sur
ce problème des vieux travailleurs
[Musique]
papa
et nous crierons tellement fort qu'on
finira par nos entendre
avec le temps des cerises Jean-Paul Le
Chat Noir gagne ses galons de
réalisateurs le film soutient une mesure
phare du franc populaire et reprend les
codes narratifs de la Vie est à nous
étaient pleines de vieux moi aussi j'ai
vu ça
partout je ne voyais que des lieux
ceux qui sont assis sur les bancs
ceux qui ouvrent les portières et ceux
qui ne peuvent plus les ouvrir
ceux qui vendent les journaux avec des
voix qu'on entend plus
ceux qui tirent qui poussent des
charrettes trop lourdes
le temps des cerises sort dans les
salles de cinéma mais la critique et la
réception du public sont mitigées
dépassé l'entre-soi comme une liste pour
toucher un large public n'est pas un
objectif facile à atteindre
la signature du pacte germano-soviétique
entraîne l'interdiction du Parti
communiste
après la débâcle le PCF devenu
clandestin s'investit peu à peu dans la
Résistance
quelques poignées de militants
s'efforcent de répandre les mots d'ordre
de créer un réseau qui malgré les
consignes de Vichy et la surveillance de
l'occupant pour atteindre jusqu'aux plus
petit village
la production cinématographique est au
point mort et il faut attendre la
libération pour voir des films qui
reconstituent et glorifient l'action des
résistants communistes il faut que le
pays sache qu'il y a des Français qui
luttent
refuse de se soumettre la vieille
demoiselle des PTT qui transmet les
messages travaille pour la résistance le
paysan qui ravitaille le maquis
travaille pour la résistance le
terroriste qui détruit les trains de
munitions travaillent pour la résistance
à la Libération la PCF est en position
de force c'est le premier parti de
France en terme de résultats électoraux
et d'effectifs militants il participe au
gouvernement aux côtés du général de
Gaulle
[Musique]
le Parti communiste met en scène sa
propre puissance en finançant un
reportage consacré à la première Fête de
l'Humanité de l'après-guerre et doit
être diffusé en avant programme dans les
cinémas
[Musique]
chaque année les
lactées se rendaient en masse à la fête
de Garches organisée par leur journal
après une interruption de 5 ans imposé
par l'occupation allemande la partie
communiste le plus grand parti français
et son journal l'Humanité renouveler la
tradition dans le magnifique bois de
Vincennes y a près de cadre nécessaire
pour accueillir un million de parisiens
et bientôt apparaissent sur l'immense
scène à trois plateaux les premiers
figurants du grand spectacle inédit
monté à cette occasion
ombre et lumière
[Musique]
mais dans les forêts à l'appel du Parti
communiste français et patriote sont
groupés et organisés en groupe armés ils
attaquent les convois ennemis font des
rayer des trains les causes des pertes
sanglantes aux essais
j'ai la joie immense et la grande fierté
de remettre
au camarades pour vous
un mineur de bruit en Artois
la carte du millionnaire adhérents du
parti communiste français
l'image est au service d'une propagande
par le chiffre
l'impressionnante full rassemblée doit
montrer que le PCF est bel et bien
devenu un parti de masse
et le soir amènera avec lui de nouveau
plaisir
comme partout dans la société française
le Parti communiste exerce un pouvoir
d'attraction important dans les milieux
artistiques et intellectuels
[Musique]
bonsoir
dans le monde du cinéma de nombreux
professionnels adhèrent au PCF pour
beaucoup ils sont également membre de la
CGT le syndicat majoritaire parmi les
techniciens du cinéma qui est largement
sous influence communiste
certains compagnons de route deviennent
rapidement célèbres dans l'après-guerre
comme Gérard Philipe Yves Montand encore
Simone Signoret
au printemps 1946 les gouvernements
français et américains signent des
accords économiques ont une annexe
concerne au cinéma ce sont les accords
Bloom Burns
interdit sous l'Occupation les films
américains peuvent désormais être
importés en France sans restriction
entrée au PCF pour résister pendant la
guerre le réalisateur Louis d'Aquin
devient le cinéaste du parti dans
l'après-guerre à la tête du syndicat CGT
des techniciens du film il est aux
avant-postes du combat à venir
l'Amérique avait produit beaucoup de
films pendant la guerre
que nous nous en avions produits très
peu et ça aurait été vraiment l'invasion
du marché français par le Seigneur
américain ça ça a été une très belle
bataille qui s'est livrée
[Musique]
soutenant les comités de défense du
cinéma français la CGT et le PCF relais
et amplifient les revendications tout en
les utilisant pour dénoncer
l'impérialisme américain
[Musique]
et j'ai commencé à avoir conscience que
dans toutes les difficultés qu'avaient
la France si on s'est défendait pas et
bien l'Amérique elle est en allait avoir
une nouvelle pas une occupation mais une
colonisation très réelle
spectateurs et amis du cinéma français
vous êtes tranquillement assis dans
votre fauteuil venu au cinéma pour vous
distraire et voici que ma voix à travers
une mince pellicule et un haut-parleur
vient troubler votre quiétude
c'est que voyez-vous le cinéma français
a besoin de vous
parce qu'il est en danger de mort
c'est tout de même abruti le vote à
l'unanimité moins une loi à l'Assemblée
nationale du fond de soutien du cinéma
qui a été un ballon d'oxygène il prélevé
aussi en partie serait les recettes des
films américains
ce fond de soutien géré par le Centre
national de la cinématographie pose la
première pierre d'un financement régulé
par les pouvoirs publics qui garantit
encore aujourd'hui la vitalité du cinéma
cette forte implication du Parti
communiste dans la défense du cinéma
traduit un changement de position
politique
en soutenant les mobilisations sociales
le PCF est exclu du gouvernement et
redevient un parti d'opposition
au printemps 1945 c'est l'entrée en
guerre froide
[Musique]
la mine paysage durent et sombres ou la
poussière noire recouvre tout la mine
des corps de roman prétextes à belles
images sources inépuisables d’effet
faciles mais la mine casse encore
surtout et avant tout des hommes
avec la grande lutte des mineurs le
cinéma communiste change radicalement de
temps
et ces images imposent un terrible
rapprochement les enfants qui fuient des
soldats qui montent images de guerre
images de la guerre que le gouvernement
déclare au peuple ce parallèle lourd de
sens avec l'occupation doit dénoncer la
violence de la répression pendant la
grève des mineurs de l'automne 1948
[Musique]
réaliser et collectivement la grande
lutte des mineurs a certainement été
supervisée par Louis Daquin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cherchant à concilier son engagement
communiste et son métier de réalisateur
il est en train de terminer le point du
jour
dans cette fiction consacrée au mineur
et l'offre son premier grand rôle à
Michel Piccoli
ce tournage a sans doute permis à Louis
Daquin d'avoir des contacts utiles pour
la grande lutte des mineurs
à partir du moment où je voulais aussi
faire un film avec des personnages
différents de ceux que l'on montrait et
dire avec des ouvriers c'est normal que
je sois attiré par les mineurs et alors
il s'est trouvé que entre temps il y a
eu une grande grève des mineurs où il y
a eu vraiment une campagne de presse
contre les mineurs on disait mais
pourquoi font-ils ce sont les gens les
plus payés
ce métier ne feriez vous messieurs les
politiciens le furiez-vous pour ce
salaire de misère le furiez-vous pour
14300 francs par mois
la dignation de Louis d'Aquin est
partagée par les techniciens qui
réalisent bénévolement ce film à la
demande de la CGT qui est alors ce
contrôle du PCF
les menteuses jouent un rôle essentiel
elles assemblent en sous-main les images
tournées dans les bassins miniers et
récupère des pellicules d'actualité
cinématographiques
remontez avec un autre commentaire elle
révèle l'ambition du film
répondre au discours des médias
officiels avec des contrats
de dégagement des puits se sont
accompagnés de bagarres parfois
violentes mais les objectifs que
s'étaient fixés les forces de
police la police lance des bombes
lacrymogènes importées
[Musique]
les mineurs Romains
dans cette lutte inégale ils parviennent
encore à rendre coup pour coup avec ses
armes improvisées et on trouvera la
guerre froide est aussi une guerre des
images
à peine terminée le film est censuré les
bobines de la grande lutte des mineurs
sont saisis par le ministère de
l'Intérieur qui juge le film trop
subversif il faudra attendre les années
70 pour qu'il soit visible
[Applaudissements]
dans ce contexte tendu disposé de ses
propres moyens de production et de
diffusion est indispensable pour faire
exister un cinéma de parties
le PCF crée la société procinex pour
être efficace sa gestion est confiée à
un professionnel expérimenté claudeger
il s'est illustré dans la lutte contre
les accords blumburns alors qu'il était
en poste au Centre national de la
cinématographie révoqué en raison de ses
idées et communistes il prend les reines
de procimex pour accompagner la
réalisation de nombreux courts métrages
en 1949 pour le 70e anniversaire de
Staline la production de l'homme que
nous aimons le plus est lancé en grande
pompe
la lune à 70 ans sur les grands routes
de France dans les villes et les
villages de l'Auvergne à la Bretagne de
la Provence à la Flandre de la Gascogne
à la Lorraine
c'est de partout vers Paris devant
l'amour pour Staline
sans la victoire de Stalingrad notre
village Grigny serait toujours
occupé par les nazis comme toute la
France comme toute l'Europe aussi nous
tous paysans de Grigny nous souhaitons
un bon anniversaire et longue vie au
généraliste Staline qui nous a libéré
par sa victoire
alors signe avec nous monsieur Vidal
le film est construit autour de la
fabrication et de l'envoi des cadeaux à
Staline
du Picasso à ta santé Staline répète les
vignerons qui lui offre le clairon qui
sonna les grèves du Midi en 1907 les
artistes communistes les plus célèbres
n'hésite pas à porter leur contribution
le poète Paul Eluard écrit le texte d'un
commentaire totalement décomplexé
dans le coeur de Staline
sans sa raison ardente les blés ne
lèveraient pas aujourd'hui pour nous
ceux qui les font pousser le savent
le culte de la personnalité autour de
Staline atteint son apogée avec l'homme
que nous aimons le plus le Parti
communiste revendique fièrement
frénétiquement stalinien
nous proclamons notre amour ardeur pour
Staline et nous assurons de notre
confiance inébranlable
vive à jamais notre cher et grand
Staline vive le communisme
[Applaudissements]
comme les deux faces d'une même pièce le
pro soviétisme va de pair avec une
critique virulente des États-Unis
[Applaudissements]
en France on aime le bon vin
les Américains en Amérique réalisé en
1950 en est l'illustration parfaite
et on sait l'apprécier
la bataille idéologique se joue aussi
dans les bistrots français
[Musique]
allez mon bonhomme placez votre Camelot
en Amérique
[Musique]
Tunis capitale de la Tunisie
simultanément à ses projets impulsés par
la direction du PCF de jeunes cinéastes
communistes professionnels ou amateurs
prennent seul l'initiative de réaliser
des films en dehors de toute commande du
parti c'est un phénomène nouveau avec
Raymond Vogel Jean-Jacques Sirkis ou
René Vautier un cinéma de fran-tireurs
se développe tournez à quelques mois
d'intervalle Afrique 50 et terres
tunisienne peuvent être considérés comme
les deux premiers films anticholoniaux
français
il y a quelques années encore j'étais
paysan
j'avais une terre à la bouée
et cultivé des légumes mûrissantes au
soleil dans l'attente du marché
ils enfants pouvaient courir et s'amuser
le long du chemin qui bordait notre
maison pendant que la femme de mon fils
mettait le pain au four
cette vie laborieuse il ne reste que
ruine des murs coulant et un foyer
abandonné le tournage de terre
tunisienne a lieu pendant l'été 1950
avec une caméra 16 mm et de la pellicule
payée par le Parti communiste tunisien
dans ce pays qui est encore sous
protectorat français et prise de vue
sont clandestine
Raymond Vogel et JeanJacques Sirkis se
font passer pour de simples touristes
prenant le risque de se faire arrêter à
tout moment
c'est ce qui leur permet d'enregistrer
des images rarissimes pour l'époque de
la misère et de l'exploitation du peuple
tunisien
[Musique]
mais pour avoir un toit ils ont dû
construire avec de la boue et des
pierres
une fois terminé terres tunisienne n'est
pas diffusée le PCF ne s'intéresse pas à
se brûlot anti-colonial et ne cherche
pas à le soutenir ces gens qui ne
reflètent pas suffisamment ces positions
sur la question coloniale
car tunisienne apparaît donc comme un
révélateur il est difficile pour les
cinéastes communistes professionnels ou
amateurs de s'affranchir de la direction
du parti
[Musique]
la libération nationale pour la paix la
terre et le pain les impérialistes
croient pouvoir disposer de nous comme
chers à nous mais nous ne sommes pas
prêts à mourir pour le salut de notre
oppresseur et blocage interne sont une
première limite qui empêche la diffusion
des films mais le principal obstacle
vient surtout de l'extérieur
à l'heure de la guerre froide la censure
bat son plein pour des motifs politiques
tous les vis à exploitation sont refusés
si le PCF parvient à un faire réaliser
des films il reste interdit de
projection dans les salles les
diffusions est dans une impasse en
restant cantonné aux réseaux communistes
le cinéma de parties ne prêche
finalement que des convaincus
ce constat d'un certain échec amène le
producteur Claude Geiger a développé de
nouveaux projets cinématographiques au
contenu moins politique
le documentaire mon ami Pierre est la
fiction majanet et mes copains jouent la
carte du cinéma social et humaniste
[Musique]
avec les copains il y a aussi l'amour de
Jeannet il y a aussi l'amour de Jean
pour toucher un large public la chanson
titre est confiée au chanteur et
comédiens Mouloudji dans ma Jeannette et
mes copains
et à Yves Montand dans mon ami Pierre
capitaine sur le chalutier finir 20
jours sur mer de jours sur terre 20
jours la mer de jour Marie
et l'année passée c'est la vie
le succès est au rendez-vous mon ami
Pierre est primé à la Mostra de Venise
en 1951
convaincu qu'il y a une nouvelle voie à
suivre Claude geigère dénoue les liens
de procinex avec le Parti communiste il
abandonne les films militants pour la
production de longs-métrages de fiction
novembre 56 la lueur blafarde de
l'incendie allumée en Hongrie a fait
croire un moment à la réaction que le
socialisme allait être abattu
après l'intervention sanglante de
l'Armée rouge à Budapest le siège du PCF
à Paris est saccagé par des manifestants
anti-communiste
l'année 1956 est un choc le rapport
coûte chef vient de révéler les crimes
du stalinisme le PCF refuse toute remise
en cause et n'hésite pas à trahir la
réalité des événements hongrois pour
soutenir le grand frère soviétique
mais le 44 est enflamme et la police a
reçu l'ordre d'appréhender qui les
camarades qui auraient pu voler au
secours du siège de leur partie à cela
on interdit le passage pour laisser les
mains libres aux autres éléments
abreuver de propagande anti-communistes
et entraîné par des fascistes semblables
à ceux contre lesquels l'Union
soviétique est intervenue à Hongrie et
qui s'apprêtait à ranimer le spectre de
la guerre au cœur de l'Europe
cet aveuglement entraîne une hémorragie
au sein du PCF de nombreux militants et
sympathisants en premier lieu des
intellectuels et des artistes comme le
cinéaste Raymond Vogel où le couple
montant signerait quitte le parti
de France à Marseille pendant près d'une
décennie l'activité cinématographique se
réduit considérablement et le PCL se
recentre sur ses propres références
culturelles et politiques
sur tous les chemins
l'humain dans toutes les mains bonjour
bonsoir
bon matin
il y a le blé et le vin il y a la laine
et
du mal dans toutes les mains sur tous
les chemins
l'humain
vous étiez au milieu des années 60 la
télévision débarque dans les foyers des
Français et devient la principale source
d'information et de divertissement
le PCF commande un reportage dans
l'esprit de cinq colonnes à la une
émission d'information la plus
emblématique de l'époque
[Musique]
le magazine Reflet suit notamment la
venue du cosmonaute Youri Gagarine qui
déchaîne les passions à Paris et dans la
cité qui porte son nom à Ivry-sur-Seine
ça faisait si longtemps qu'on
l'attendait cet homme là et quand il est
enfin venu à Paris 2 ans après son
exploit ça a été une joie formidable
dans toute la France
[Applaudissements]
le premier cosmonaute
reflet poursuit la tradition des
contractualités communistes tout en
profitant des améliorations techniques
et des caméras plus légères
on y sent à la fois l'influence du
cinéma direct et de la télévision le
dispositif du micro-trottoir fait son
apparition
[Applaudissements]
où il était là devant la voiture je sais
pas la France des 30 glorieuses qui
changent à toute allure la parole est
également donnée aux jeunes une classe
d'âge qui prend une importance nouvelle
dans la société
nous les avons rencontrés au cours de
leur dernière vacances nous avons
surpris leur jeu comme on surprend dans
la jungle de jeunes animaux sauvages ou
craintifs en prenant bien garde de ne
pas les effaroucher par nos
interventions
car une sorte de frontière sépare de
leurs aînés ces garçons et ses filles
chez qui l'on découvre un appétit de
vivre féroce et joyeux
avez-vous une idée une opinion politique
ce silence cette non-réponse ce n'est
pas de l'indifférence mais beaucoup plus
sûrement une sorte de pudeur la crainte
de dire une naïveté d'engager ses
parents et finalement le respect de la
lutte des adultes à laquelle ils ne sont
pas très sûrs d'être dignes de
participer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en mai 68 ce sont pourtant eux qui
tiennent le haut du pavé et secouent la
France gaullistes
c'est dans cette ébullition que se
tiennent les États généraux du cinéma
français qui se donnent pour objectif de
réorganiser l'industrie
cinématographique
c'est au sein de la commission diffusion
que de jeunes communistes du cinéma
organisent de nombreuses projections
dans les usines occupées il réalise que
les films produits par le PC sont
inaccessibles et dépassés
parmi eux il y a Jacques bidou il a tout
juste terminé ses études de cinéma et
participe à la création du collectif dit
Nadia avec l'envie de dépoussiérer le
cinéma du parti
donc la première chose qu'on fait c'est
cet outil très rustique très
rudimentaire disant gollyme c'est à dire
174 diapositives accompagnées d'un texte
lu c'est-à-dire que donc on est vraiment
sur du très basique très économique et
c'est vrai que d'une certaine façon ça a
fonctionné c'est à dire que notre jeu de
diapositive a eu un certain succès et on
est assez fier de notre première
initiative
la presse 68 est marquée par une
embellie du cinéma militant des dizaines
de collectifs voient le jour parmi
lesquels les groupes mettentine portés
par Chris Marker et le groupe digavertof
de Jean-Luc Godard s'il rejette le PCF
sur le plan politique il s'inspire de
ces méthodes pour produire et diffuser
leur film
dynadia se démarque par son engagement
au PCF considérant que seuls ce parti
puissant et structuré peut changer la
société
pour agir de collectif réalise un film
sur la campagne de Jacques Duclos lors
de la présidentielle de 1969
je dirais qu'à ce moment-là nous n'avons
pas comme préoccupation la question
cinématographique même si nous sommes
des jeunes cinéastes qui nous
préoccupent uniquement c'est l'action
politique et d'ailleurs on a
probablement à ce moment-là une vision
très instrumentale où les questions
formelles sont secondaires
Jacques Duclos est suivi caméra à
l'épaule au jour le jour ce qui permet
d'être au plus près de l'événement
politique et de mettre en scène la bonne
amie du candidat et comme une liste dans
la lutte documente également l'irruption
de la télévision dans la vie politique
vous n'avez pas exporter des milliards
en Suisse pour jouer le Dodge sur le
Dolce
et l'art de la petite phrase l'adresse
face caméra du candidat goyor qui
cherche à se rendre sympathique et la
mauvaise foi le soir du premier tour
annonce pour les années à venir la
politique spectacle qui se développe
avec les sorts de la télévision
[Musique]
vous faites la course contrairement pour
venir
oui mais je ne marche pas dans une
affaire personnelle
la campagne de Jacques Duclos est une
réussite avec 22% des voix et les 3e à
l'issue du premier tour
et communistes dans la lutte est
largement diffusée dans les réseaux
communistes ce qui convain la direction
de donner de nouveaux moyens collectifs
il devient la société de production
unicité avec pour devises filmées pour
un parti
des dizaines de films documentaires sont
mis en route en France et à l'étranger
grâce au financement venu du PCF
certains thèmes de prédilection
communiste sont repris comme le film de
banlieue pour renouveler l'approche une
réflexion sur la forme émerge
progressivement
en 1973 dans vivre mieux changer la vie
l'angle choisit et celui de l'intime
en suivant le quotidien d'une famille
d'ouvriers en région parisienne que le
programme commun autour duquel le PC le
PS viennent de s'unir et présenter
Bernard delbouy dit nanar 34 ans marié
trois enfants
bien que cela n'apparaisse pas de ces
images banales et bien qu'il ne soit pas
parmi les plus défavorisés Bernard
delbouiller sa famille vivent mal très
mal la crise leur colle à la peau
d'après ce que tu vas voir de ta vie
qu'est-ce qui pourrait changer pour toi
avec le programme commun
l'ensemble du point commun ça va nous
permettre de mieux vivre et d'avenir
pleinement notre vie
[Musique]
quand on aura les 40 sultans de travail
est réduit on retrouve à l'envie de
faire quelque chose on aura le temps et
le goût de vivre tous les gens qui en
ont marre ça se retrouve dans un bloc de
grandes ensemble comme sud de la Grande
Borne
il y a un effort qui a été fait pour le
rendre plus agréable pour les habitants
mais actuellement les gens qui habitent
ils n'ont pas le temps d'en profiter ils
ont trop de soucis la mise en scène
cherche à exprimer l'espoir d'un avenir
meilleur dans les grands ensembles
construits par les municipalités
communistes qui sont ici magnifiées par
l'image
je trouve qu'on peut avoir plaisir à
flâner comme ça à partir un peu à la
découverte tu vois
[Musique]
on a compris que sans écriture
ça ne fonctionnait pas ça dire ça ne
touchait pas un grand cinéaste qui a des
choses à nous raconter quand c'est la
documentait ou fiction mes documentaires
s'il y a pas de cinéma ça marche pas
c'est une conception de l'urbanisme
comme celle-là était généralisée bah les
gens qui habitent ici ils pourraient
réellement vivre et profiter de ce corps
c'est un peu seul le programme commun
[Musique]
moment Bagnolet et Carrefour de l'Est
parisien donne une toute autre vision de
la banlieue
conseil municipal a pris il y a 15 ans
décision de moderniser sa ville alors
nous avons commencé par le plateau des
Malassis là où il y avait des terrains
de culture
en jouant sur les références du cinéma
expérimental sur un ton décalé et
ironique le montage alterné révèle les
paradoxes et les absurdités de la vie
dans les grands ensembles ce qui remet
directement en cause l'action des élus
communistes
sur un chantier existant si bien qu'il y
a énormément de gens qui se retrouvent
dans la boue du matin au soir pour se
rendre à leur voiture ou au métro
[Musique]
et si personne ne se connaît par ses
voisines de paliers c'est tout et encore
on se dit bonjour bonsoir c'est tout je
trouve que ça manque de quelque chose
les réalisateurs d'unicité affirment des
points de vue d'auteur qui ne
correspondent pas forcément à la ligne
générale du PCF
une première fissure apparaît
elle s'amplifie avec les mésaventures du
réalisateur Gérard Guillaume
[Musique]
en pleine guerre du Vietnam Gérard
Guillaume entame une fresque
documentaire
les chemins de la victoire doit soutenir
le peuple vietnamien contre les
États-Unis l'alerte quotidienne est
passée la défense antérienne sur un œil
est-elle que tout va très vite
sur le chemin du retour les avions
américains l'orgueront les bombes qui
n'ont pas pu déverser sur un œil de
préférence sur les villages ou sur les
digues
[Musique]
à son retour en France en 1972 Gérard
Guillaume découvre que la direction du
parti s'est alignée sur les nouvelles
positions de Moscou qui négocie
secrètement la fin du conflit avec les
États-Unis sans les Vietnamiens
malgré le soutien d'unicité qui se
positionne contre le PCF le montage du
film s'arrête refusant de se soumettre à
l'injonction politique Gérard Guillaume
active ses réseaux pour aller au bout de
son projet il réussit à le transformer
en série documentaire pour l'ORTF
au 31 mai 1972 depuis le début de la
première escalade plus de 3600 avions
américains ont été détruits plus de 400
pilotes ont été capturés
pourquoi
[Musique]
même si des cinéastes comme Gérard
Guillaume s'éloigne le PCF reste un
parti attractif avec près de 500 000
adhérents en 1975
pour élargir encore sa base militante un
nouveau film est commandé l'adhésion
je suis comme une liste pourquoi pas
vous
Daniel Auteuil y joue un jeune homme
inquiet de voir sa compagne adhérer au
PCF
ça y est j'ai atterri
mon bichon
allez bisous bisous
l'adhésion cherche à convaincre les
femmes d'entrer au PCF
alors que l'émancipation féminine est au
cœur des débats en France la bataille
est encore loin d'être gagnée
[Applaudissements]
aux partis quand
vendredi soir vendredi dernier oui
vendredi dernier je peux vous demander
pourquoi vous avez adhéré
depuis longtemps je fais partie du Parti
communiste depuis X années et que ma
femme n'était pas encore
après la rupture du programme commun le
PS dépasse le PCF au législatives de
que c'est une majorité le parti resserre
le contrôle sur unicité pour aller
contre le basculement politique qui se
perd mais le problème reste le même les
films ne touchent pas le grand public
notre échec par rapport au fait que nous
ne ferons pas la révolution de la
communication par le cinéma dans en
interne et que nous n'avons pas accès à
ce qui est en train d'évoluer
massivement qui est la télévision
[Musique]
la présidentielle de 1981 est un retour
à la case départ
à nouveau la direction du Parti
communiste produit un film pour suivre
son candidat c'est l'espoir au présent
du nom du programme de Georges Marchais
je l'ai dit publiquement
et moi je le dis avant les élections
je dis
au-dessus de 4 millions d'anciens francs
de revenus par mois il faut tout prendre
malgré ses fanfaronnades et son
franc-parler Georges Marchais arrive
seulement en quatrième position lors du
premier tour pour lui qui se voyait
devant le candidat socialiste c'est la
douche froide
l'élection de François Mitterrand
confirme et accélère le repli électoral
communiste
dans un style télévisuel qui n'a plus
rien de cinématographique le reportage
consacré à la Fête de l'Humanité de 1981
illustre cette période charnière les
militants s'expriment sur la victoire de
la gauche avec un enthousiasme relatif à
désillusion semble peindre comme si le
déclin politique du PCF était
inélectable
[Musique]
le changement c'est quoi pour vous
respirer un peu mieux non on respire un
peu mieux depuis 10 semaines
c'est déjà un certain nombre de
décisions qui sont prises ça suffit
peut-être pas mais c'est déjà c'est déjà
ça non on s'aperçoit que ça vient mais
tu vois petit à petit alors on sait pas
où on va là maintenant bon facile de se
solutionner leurs paroles on devrait
être gagnant que tu en penses
ce film est l'une des dernières
réalisations d'unicité qui cesse ses
activités quelques années plus tard
l'érosion politique du parti communiste
entraîne la disparition de sa production
cinématographique
les années 80 actent le passage à la
communication audiovisuelle
il reste de cette histoire une aventure
humaine et artistique faite de figures
populaires et charismatique
et centaines de films qui sont
aujourd'hui le témoignage d'une culture
propre au PCF
[Musique]
et surtout la trajectoire d'une force
politique qui aura compris avant les
autres l'importance de la propagande par
l'image
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]